time for the week 14 play update it's
time for the damn you item shifter nice
try rappaport uh should we be doing this
in front of an active volcano
everything is totally normal but please
dealers come over here here actually
hurry move again oh look ketchup
oh cheese
wait who's in the nfc e-spot hi i'm kurt
uncles and i play for the delaware clan
okay let's move gruden out oh per adam
chapter gruden's out i risk catching
love for this man any room for oh god
our house
do you smell what the lava is cooking
it's us yo man they can stay with me
oh there's a volcano here that's why the
nfl has added precautions for safety
hold on i'm very disappointed in you
drew block all right culture somehow in
the photo bring in their most exciting
players hi i'm rodrigo blankenship this
is just like the star wars
planet mustafar according to reports
lamar's taking a step back i have not
taken a step ah i am now hearing that
volcano is in fact out of control but
let me at run for your lives
make the playoffs
[Music]
this way